alors l'idée est venue de ce qui existe
dans l'état du maine depuis en fait les
années 80 un réseau de plus de 400 km de
sentier maritime pour amateurs de canoë
kayak et nous sommes nombreux
alors il ya quatre ans la fédération de
canoë kayak du québec s'est dit pourquoi
pas faire la même chose autour de
montréal après tout on vit sur une île
cette année cette route bleue existe et
elle est très populaire d'ailleurs elle
s'agrandit en ajoutant un tronçon de 150
km entre delson et sainte anne de sorel
aux 150 km déjà existants émilie
dubreuil
ça fait plus de 50 ans que robert
racicot navigue sur le lac saint-louis
lac avec lequel il a développé un
rapport plutôt intime et vient points
sont sur le côté au milieu ça peu près
la même chose que l'accès au lac saint
louis c'est la vieille poil au japon a
fait sien le vieux capitaine est ravie
qu'on ait choisi d'organiser ici
l'événement qui marquera le lancement de
la nouvelle saison de la route bleue une
descente du lac saint louis pour toute
la famille le 31 mai prochain
car son lac sa vieille poil comme il dit
il voudrait bien que les montréalais le
redécouvre on a du bon poisson
maintenant du donc depuis aux trente ans
l'eau améliorer aussi sur le lac saint
louis mais maintenant ils font des tests
d'eau qui est même plus baignable car
certaines plages autour de nous n'avons
rien
kayakistes passionnés alexandre richette
ce sera l'un des guides pour amener les
néophytes sur le lac saint-louis lé 31
me donc on démarre de sainte anne de
bellevue ont fait lac saint louis
on poursuit dans les rapides de lachine
ici puis on savoir comme ça jusqu'à
l'est de montréal
mais ce qui compte pour cet ambassadeur
de la route bleue ce ne sont pas les
kilomètres parcourus mais bien le
symbole leur majorité des accès à l'eau
ont été privatisées dans leur année à
montréal on peut parler de 50 ans où il
y avait des plus d'une soixantaine
d'accès à l'eau des plages publiques et
tous avec le comité zip ville-marie puis
différents partenaires on essaie de
redonner l'accès à l'eau on serait de on
essaie avec les municipalités d'acheter
des nouveaux terrains riverains
en fait c'est une problématique sociale
on doit ouvrir la ville vers l'eau la
ville de la chine partenaire de la route
bleue et de la descente du lac st-louis
a d'ailleurs racheté dans les dernières
années les terrains riverains du
centre-ville en notre histoire nous est
basée sur l'eau alors je pense qu'en
2014 qu'on en fasse la promotion pour
enfin le pourtour en bateau pense que
c'est une cause exceptionnel noble
naturel et pleine de santé les gens qui
veulent participer à la descente du lac
saint-louis peuvent s'inscrire sur le
site de la route bleue émilie dubreuil
radio canada montréal